irène chagnaud propose voyage sans
passeport
à 545 km du continent à munich est en
plein océan atlantique madère madre à la
portugaise on aborde bien entendu à vol
d'oiseau les caravelles de l'infant
henry prince de sa graisse la découvre
en 14,165 elle est parée de forêt d'où
son nom madé ira bois
enfin
voilà vous l'avez vu son climat sain et
clément les fleurs y sont reines au
coeur même de foule car la végétation
est luxuriante regarder l'aspect de
funchal sa capitale la capitale de
madère bâtiment blanc bordées de pierre
noire est partout partout des fleurs
celles ci jouent elles jouent à cacher
quelque chose quoi regarder et oui une
rivière une rivière qui est très sèche
l'été et qui abrite sa honte
derrière les bougainvilliers
couvent église et soldats aux fenêtres
de moins cela est possible à madère car
depuis l'avènement de la république les
couvents sont occupés par l'armée
et
tout est plaisant apaisant souillant la
nature ici est forte elle si forte que
même la partie utilitaires reste
agréable
le matin est bien le matin il porte le
lait il faut aux livreurs une véritable
endurance car aucune chaussure ne
résiste aux galets ronds qui font les
routes alors bien ils y vont pieds nus
les chariots aussi ont décidé d'être
originaux et pour ce faire il se passe
de roue
là bas on ne roule pas on glisse et
lorsque la poutre est usé eh bien mon
dieu on en met une autre c'est simple
rapide et efficace
ça évite les roues voilées
et je ne crois pas que ce soit beaucoup
plus bruyant qu'une route bois
parking en tout genre
contraste amusant de voir lequel le
visiteur le touriste plus tôt ou
visiteurs n'hésitent pas longtemps
remonter si près des côtes américaines
au temps des rois fainéants
voilà de quoi vous faire rêver mais de
nouveau sa guise
mais à force de glisser le patin chauffe
alors pendant qu'un homme conduit
l'attelage l'autre court devant avec un
chiffon gras il le pose sur la route et
le patin glisse dessus en s'imprégnant
une fois d'un côté une fois de l'ordre
comme ça pas de jaloux et pas de risques
d'incendié c'est fatigant pour le
conducteur
mais il n'est pas interdit de se servir
de ses jambes et c'est un sûr moyen de
découverte
autre moyen de transport celui ci sans
aucune fatigue pour celui qui dans le
hamac et nous arrivons dans le village
de monde et c'est là que se réfugia pour
y mourir
charles 1er dernier empereur régnant
d'autriche
ce village est sis à 600 mètres
d'altitude et il est une station
climatériques important
toujours le calme la fraîcheur
et c'est du haut de ses six cents mètres
que l'on descend par ce moyen
regardez bien 50 la séance hier la
colline et c'est en freinant avec leurs
pieds que les deux hommes les deux
conducteurs vous faut arriver en bas
sans encombre malgré quelques émotions
attention attention attention et non
tout va très bien vous voyez il suffit
d'avoir confiance
une princesse de sang royal ayant été
atteinte au chai plus dernier d'une
maladie pulmonaire sa mère la princesse
marie amélie a fait construire et à
laisser les fonds nécessaires à cette
maison les soeurs qui l'occupé qui
soigne son française
vous
devant examinons maintenant les
industries du pays canne à sucre à
profusion le coupeur de sacs de canne à
sucre porte le béret que l'on rencontre
sur toute l'île regardez bien c'est un
curieux mélange de nos passe montagne
qui aurait la forme d'un casque gaulois
il faut voir là une influences venues de
france des hommes s'occupent des
bananeraies aux fruits somptueux formes
étranges
l'effet est tout autre que suspendu chez
l'épicier du coin n'est ce pas mais
c'est la braderie qui occupent la
plupart des femmes de cette île on leur
donne la toile déjà dessiné et le
matériel nécessaire souvent une famille
entière travail toute une année sur la
même pièce et c'est cette collaboration
mutuelle qui permet d'obtenir un fini
parfait
regardez ce travail de patience
une fois la pièce terminée elle et
l'avait blanchi à prêter et mon dieu
elle ne dépas aucune table même la plus
raffinée